may i please
ask you oh i'm so fascinated
you
like did a talk show what did you think
and feel like sometimes i go home at
night and think do people think like i
asked them appropriate questions like
you know i have all these
questions every night i really do i like
stare
like should i sit on the floor when i'm
talking to you is that going to come off
weird but it's what i'm inclined to do
[Music]
drew i think you just be you all right
and if it means getting down on the
floor like this this is what we do
my my knees are killing me okay we can
thank you
excuse me
did you did you um
yeah that but i know i you you you i
love your talk show that was a weird
moment wasn't it
you really just uh i've never seen that
before i in all the years i've seen a
lot of talk shows i've not seen anybody
do the the uh the seat to floor combo
before so that's i would love
like not only for you to tell me like
how you think i'm doing in this job but
also what would talk soup say about this
nut ball of a shower right right what
would we do oh my god we'd have a lot of
good materials
like a a complete nutter butter like me
i
there you would be useful yes i would i
think i would but i will give you this
last tip which is please uh when i did
my talk show we had a book
and everybody would sign the book
now i notice i did not either i was
asked you know we don't need greg to
sign the book or you may not have a book
i never thought to do that because we
launched in a pandemic and everybody was
on zoom and nobody would come here and
so okay we're going to get you a book
we're going to get you a book and
and here's my second piece of advice
i'll be the first one to sign your book
but here's my second piece of advice is
don't don't then finish the show
and and realize like a year later
where's the book
because i don't have the book from all
the years i did later i i had like a
like a huge book with everybody signed
it and stuff and i'm sure i said
glowing things about me and i i never i
never found the book so that's
interesting i just found an article
about this woman who has become a
treasure huntress
maybe i need to call her and see if she
can help us track it down
really yes i just found this woman so
she can find like that's what she mean
anything that's what she does oh god i
got a lot of jobs for her man
well i think we know mission number one
i'm going to get the book i'm going to
find this woman see if we can find your
old book and now that we know each other
we can be friends okay very good i love
it
shining veil is available through
streaming on stars and the stars app it
is so awesome
[Music]